wonderful so thank you very much
everybody for coming
um today i'm going to be really as umesh
said
diving into new methods for simulating
hamiltonian dynamics and
at a high level one of the things you
might think of going into this
talk is you might think okay this is
going to be
a quantum chemistry talk uh it actually
won't be
really the way to look at this is i i
want to show you
a bunch of techniques that you can think
of as ways of building
new classes of hamiltonians and how to
manipulate
these types of operations and these
techniques
are not haven't just revolutionized our
approaches for simulating
chemistry quantum field theory and
materials
but they've also given us fundamentally
new ways of solving other types of
algorithms for example
there's been monumental leaps in quantum
linear systems
as well as methods for solving
semi-definite programming
and as well as differential equations
that all have come out of these
techniques
and so i really strongly recommend
anybody who's interested in quantum
algorithms at this point
these techniques have gotten so rich
that at least having a basic
understanding
of how these methods work i think is
essential
in order for you to really understand
the state of the art for algorithms in
general
and so my aim here is to provide you
with some of the intuition
about what these techniques can do and
also
when you should choose one technique
over another in order to tackle a
particular problem
so as i said you know previously getting
in
one of the reasons why you would want to
do quantum simulation from a big picture
perspective
is that it provides an exponential speed
up for
a wealth of different problems now
i'd like to put this in contrast to the
original kind of killer application for
quantum computing which was of course
shora's algorithm
shora's algorithm i find a little bit of
a depressing algorithm personally
because well first off it kind of only
makes the world worse
you know in that having your
your bank transactions potentially uh
read over the internet
that doesn't make my life any better and
on top of that
because of the existence of quantum
resistant uh cryptography
um there is actually a real chance
that by the time quantum computers come
out that are capable
of um of breaking currently used key
sizes for rsa
we will actually have already
potentially moved beyond
rsa for most of our critical
communications
so this makes shore's algorithm if that
was our only thing
kind of you know a little bit of a dead
end street at some point because
you know the that problem as well as
related problems from the
say you know like abelian hidden
subgroup problem are
not necessarily going to be used uh
forever
however chemistry is likely going to be
going on forever
and so this is one of the reasons why
from my perspective
simulation really is a phenomenal area
in terms of applications
but not just that it's also as i said
a very really valuable way uh paradigm
for building up subroutines that we need
in other algorithms and i've already
mentioned linear systems of equations
but one thing that i also want to
mention
is that it's very important for
theoretic for theoretical reasons
because quantum simulation
methods also give you ways of figuring
out how much it would cost
to emulate other models of quantum
computing on a standard circuit-based
quantum computer
so for example if you wanted to do
something like adiabatic quantum
computing
which you can view as kind of an
idealization of what the d-wave machine
does
in order to be able to prove that that
model of computing can be efficiently
simulated by a quantum computer
you've got to find a way of translating
it over and quantum simulation methods
give you just that
so this is one of these are some of the
reasons why theoretically
even on top of these amazing
applications we really kind of want to
have
simulation algorithms now to give you an
idea about
what i mean by simulation this is really
important because
every subfield when they hear the word
quantum simulation
they have a different notion in their
mind of what exactly they mean
for some people it means finding the
lowest eigen eigenvalue of
a matrix for other people it means
emulating the quantum dynamics of it
typically in quantum algorithms when we
talk about quantum simulation
we kind of need more the latter
application
so in particular what quantum dynamics
the way they're described
is that let's assume that we've got a
hamiltonian matrix
h um which is confusing is all heck in
quantum computing because
we can i can never tell whether h means
the hadamard gate or the hamiltonian
uh and so um in in some cases
the best uh rule usually is just
think about which option would make the
make the formula harder and that's
probably the right guess
but all joking aside with that the um
hamiltonian itself for those of you who
haven't done much in the way of quantum
physics
is you can think of it as sort of like
the energy operator for a particular
system
it's like an energy function except it's
a matrix because
you know we've got to have make sure
that it this object is basis independent
so the object that describes how a
quantum
system ends up evolving is e to the
minus i h t
this will talk this will describe the
time evolution this unitary operation
will describe the time evolution that an
initial state will end up experiencing
for period t and so
the a couple of things are really
important for this you might ask okay
well
what's the big deal why is this so tough
well
one of the problems is that in general h
is exponentially large so if we have n
qubits to describe the problem then h is
a 2 to the n by 2 to the n matrix
and in general good luck squaring a 2 to
the n by 2 to the n matrix
so how are we going to evaluate this
definition of the operator exponential
up here
in fact actually generically even if we
can figure out some structure
uh to evaluate the non-zero matrix
elements
of the this exponentially large
hamiltonian matrix
still figuring out an explicit
representation of this guy on the left
is incredibly difficult and so
this makes quantum simulation a really
challenging compilation problem
because of the fact that well we don't
know explicitly what our target is
but in any case to give you an idea
about what this form of quantum
stimulation means i really have want to
introduce two worlds to you
and so the first world is the world of
the physical system
this is the world of this actual h
matrix
over here so this is the world of the
system that um
that we want to simulate this might be
chemistry this might
actually be the hamiltonian that we're
using inside a linear systems algorithm
this could be the this is the thing that
we want
the key thing is is that we have this
evolution
starting from some initial state going
forward in time to a final state
over here and that's described by this e
to the minus i h t
operator that i was discussing now
in order to simulate this what we do is
we take this initial state over here and
we have to build a rule
and this rule will translate allow us to
translate between states in the physical
world
to states qubit states in our quantum
computer
then once we've done that we want to
break this up into a discrete sequence
of gate operations that
will emulate some quantum dynamics going
from the initial state to the final
state such that this final state in the
quantum computer
is logically equivalent to the final
state that we would see in the physical
system
up to some error epsilon okay
and we ideally would want to be able to
build an algorithm
that can perform this compilation and
ensure that we can hit our target within
an error of epsilon
for any user specified value of t and
epsilon
and that's the aim and of course the the
gold standard of this
is what we would like to do is we'd like
to have the number of gate operations in
here
scale as poly
a poly a poly n where n is the number of
qubits
and this is really important because as
i said before the size of
h over here is like 2 to the n by 2 to
the n
so having the quantum algorithm scale
polynomially with the number of qubits
actually often ends up giving us an
exponential advantage over the best
classical methods
so this is what our aim is with
with uh uh simulation
and so as i said before the big problem
is um okay or sorry i guess the standard
approach that you could do
is everybody knows that um that
hadamard t and c naught or universal
gate set
so if we knew what u of t was explicitly
we could always break it up
into those basic gate operations but as
i said before
we don't know what u of t is because it
would require
actually an exponential number of
classical calculations to figure out
what that matrix is
in fact actually if he even wanted to
figure this out on a quantum computer
it would take an exponentially large
number of quantum simulations too
so we cannot use at all brute force
synthesis and so
the idea behind all all simulation
methods
is to take this unitary that we want to
implement
as a sequence of gates and break it down
into a series of simple sub problems
each of these sub problems we come up
with a specific solution for
and then we combine those sub problems
back
in order to handle the overall dynamics
now there's kind of four broad
strategies
for this uh the first uh one that was
discovered was
uh trotter suzuki formulas um the second
are randomized time evolutions no
examples of this include the recently
discovered q drift simulation algorithm
as well as density matrix exponentiation
um then there's linear combinations of
unitaries
and quantum walk techniques which are
often known under the moniker
of cubitization in this talk i'm going
to be spending a lot of time talking
about
charter suzuki formulas linear
combination of unitaries
and quantum wonks if anybody's curious
about these techniques in particular i
encourage you to ask me questions
afterwards
but unfortunately with the time
constraints i don't have time to cover
all four i can only do three out of the
four
so let's talk about the first approach
so the first approach is a trotter
suzuki simulations
the whole idea behind trotter suzuki
simulations
uh is i think really kind of natural
the idea is like if when you look at me
right now in your screen
you might think you're seeing a static
or moving image
the reality is is you're not what's
happening
is that your screen is rapidly
flickering at a rate that's
faster than um what your eye can
naturally process
or at least what most people's eyes can
naturally process
uh definitely what my i faster than my
eyes can process before i've had a cup
of coffee or something
or if you those that know me better you
can coke or sex
um but in any case the um
key thing about it is that we try to do
the same thing
with the trotter suzuki formula the key
idea is let's say we've got
h as a sum of hamiltonian terms then
the time evolution operator is just e to
the negative
i uh sum over j a sub j
h j t alright
and then what we would like to do is
we'd like to be able to
use this kind of light switch
approximation we want to rapidly
switch between only one of these hj
terms being
on while all the rest of them are off
and do so so frequently
that it seems like all of them are on at
the same time
and the way that we do this is basically
by using this approximation over here
and r
over here just refers to the number of
time steps that we end up using for this
and we can see that basically
as we increase the number of flickers
effectively
that we're using for this the error that
we end up seeing in
the charter suzuki formula ends up
scaling like the nor
the sum of the norms of the commutators
times the times f squared divided by r
so by choosing this value big enough we
can drive
the error term down to be less than
epsilon for any epsilon greater than
zero
i i should mention also there's been
some great work that
that i had a small role in uh largely by
yuan su
that ended up showing that actually this
formula
over here can be generalized to
arbitrarily high orders
and so the general formula ends up
looking very similar
except if you want to use this for
higher order charter suzuki formulas
it will end up depending on more
commutators of the individual
hamiltonian terms but the idea is the
same
so the key thing that makes trotter
suzuki formulas
really kind of awesome is that
first they require no extra memory in
order to do it
all the rest of the quantum simulation
methods that i'm talking about will
require
minimally one extra quantum bit here
it's literally it's exactly the same
space
the next thing that's really cool about
it is that
the error that we end up getting in the
approximation doesn't
directly depend on how big these terms
are
rather it depends on the commutator
between
each of the individual terms so if you
have a bunch of terms
that approximately commute with each
other
then these individual terms are might be
quite small
even if the coefficients in the
hamiltonian are large
so there would be some problems like
this as people like robin kathari and
others that microsoft ended up showing
that the where the
the trotter suzuki method is much more
efficient than any other known quantum
simulation method
okay but the key part about this
simulation is i mentioned
that what we do is we break this down
into a bunch of simulations of e
these e to the minus i h js over here
and this only makes sense if we can
figure out a way of implementing
each of those e to the minus i h js
because otherwise well
all we've done is taken our original
quantum simulation problem
and broken it down into our other
quantum simulation problems
and you know and there's no clear profit
if both if both
the left-hand side and the right-hand
side are equally hard to do
so what we want to do is we want to pick
particular
h sub js that have structures that allow
us to build quantum circuits
to perform the simulation and so the
i question is what kinds of structures
can we take advantage of
so nathan there is a question that
seems to be relevant at this point in
discussion so the question
is uh whether it's whether the recent
work of you and sue its
improved high order formulas do they
yield an advantage in a natural
hamiltonian setting where somehow this
appears in physics or some other problem
so one of the things that we're
we were able to show with this is that
the
performance of these ma of these methods
comes very close
to tying the performance that we can see
for um
complicated simulation methods such as
the interaction picture simulation
method which i'll get to later
for problems in chemistry and materials
so there are actually physical
applications where
these higher order methods are formally
needed the big challenge
though is determining you know what the
relevant constant factors are and
precisely when
you're going to actually want to switch
over to these high order formulas and
that
that part isn't known yet nathan is
there an intuition as to like the
dimensionality of the lattice or
something that relates to
what order uh what order formula you
need to use
actually if the dimensionality of the
lattice doesn't have anything
directly to deal with it um the only
thing that the dimensionality of the
lattice can sometimes end up leading to
is the commutation relations that you
end up getting between the particular
terms
so sometimes more stuff will end up
commuting with each other if you've got
something like say
um just nearest neighbor interactions on
a 1d lattice
then almost everything commutes with
each other and you know you can rock on
but the thing in general that you
actually care about
more than more than the dimensionality
of the lattice is the typical size of
the commutators
so that's the biggest thing and the okay
the size of the commutators
the time you're doing the simulation for
any air tolerance you want
that'll determine it but the exact
precise crossover point where the second
or where the say the
fifth order formula is the right thing
to do versus the third order formula
that's that requires a lot of
experimentation to figure out
i i see susan has her hand up do you
have a question
no i don't it was an accident sorry okay
no worries at all
all right great so now let me talk about
the kinds of structure that we want to
um uh exploit so the key structure that
we
we will that we will take advantage of
is kind of this notion of sparsity
and so the fundamental idea ideas let's
take a look at this example
down here and i'll show you why this
particular example is an example of an
easily simulatable
matrix so first off the structure of
this may not be totally clear until i do
this
now i've colored the non-zero matrix
elements of this hamiltonian
and i've broken them into a series of
blocks so
the diagonal elements that are non-zero
i've colored
um uh green and
salmon and the off diagonal elements are
blue and gray
so first thing is let's consider
building e to the minus i h t
if we square the matrix well then what's
going to happen if we square h we're
going to multiply the green block by
the green block we'll multiply the
salmon block by the salmon block
and then we'll multiply the blue block
by the blue block so on and so forth
the for the square you can see that each
block
only talks to other matrix elements
inside the block when you do the matrix
multiplication
and so what that ends up meaning is that
when we exponentiate the hamiltonian
all we have to do to exponentiate it is
build a quantum circuit that's capable
of exponentiating
an arbitrary block that block doesn't
need to know
anything about the rest of the
exponentially large matrix
only the properties of that block and so
the key idea behind doing this is that
what we want to do is we would
like to be able to build a quantum
circuit that can identify the salient
properties of a block
simulate each of them independently and
then using quantum superposition
if we build such a circuit it will
actually be able to simulate
all exponentially many of these blocks
in a single application
so that's the key idea behind how we can
exploit a property like sparsity
in order to be able to do a simulation
easily
but to give you a particular example of
how this would uh this will work let me
show you something that you would see
all the time and it's one of the
simplest hamiltonians that you can think
of exponentiating
so let's think about just trying to
simulate a hamiltonian consists of only
one term
which is uh a times x tends or x
so the strategy that we we have is that
this matrix
first off just taking a look at it it's
of the form
so using that block language that i
described uh before
we can actually see something really
kind of obvious or indeed
that these two elements form a block
and these two form a block so you can
see that when
that this is a particular case of that
of that other sort of strategy that i
that i mentioned i.e this is a what's
known as a one sparse matrix and a
jargon
so the the strategy though is that
in this particular case all of these
blocks are basically identical
so we don't have to actually bend over
backwards to think about building a
complicated circuit
for extracting the properties of each
and every block we can kind of do it
globally
so the strategy that we do for this is
we would diagonalize the hamiltonian
which we can do by hadamard transforming
each of the
um each of the the polyx bits
then what we do is we'd like to be able
to come up with a circuit
for simulating it in general the easiest
way to do that
is to diagonalize that matrix and by
doing that we actually
see pretty straightforwardly that the
eigenvalues of the z tensor z
operator that we get in between are just
going to be uh negative one
um to the i uh exclusive or j so it's
just it goes like the parity
of the two bits and so all we have to do
is now build a unitary circuit that
kicks the right phase
back we translate then once we've done
that
all we have to do is uh transform the
circuit
into the computational basis and we're
done and the resulting circuit that we
get by following all of these steps is
this guy
over here which you've probably seen
many times
in simulations for you know chemistry as
well
as uh spin systems so
that's the particular example but the
broader strategy that you would take a a
take looking at this is the one sparse
method that i was mentioning before
next up i what i'd like to do is i'd
like to talk about linear combination of
unitaries now
lcu to be honest people have actually
been using
lcu in a lot of different names and a
lot of different contexts for a long
time
but the first time that the name was
like explicitly used
for hamiltonian simulation was in work
that
that andrew and i ended up doing and
this all started because of like an idle
question that actually i had
one day and an idle question which i
didn't think would be terribly useful
for anything
really was well okay let's take a look
at trotter methods
with trotter methods i know how to
implement them because
i can well right unitary is a product
of other unitaries so i know how to do
products of unitaries
and the stupid question i asked myself
was well
how would i do the sum of unitaries and
it turned it turns out
that this that doing the sum of
unitaries is actually really really
useful
the reason why is that when you try to
approximate
a time evolution operator as a sum of
individual terms
versus a product like e to the minus i
h1
times e to the minus i h2 then what we
end up getting
in this this case is a mat we end up
getting a series
that ends up looking like this and we
would multiply
that times 1 minus i h2
plus so if we want to be able to build
up the taylor series of the
um of e to the minus iht by the product
you end up getting this challenge that
all of these
terms start multiplying through by each
other
so as we're trying to build up the
taylor series for the time evolution
operator
we need to control how these this
exponentially growing
list of combinations for the products
and ends up actually unfolding
and that's a real challenge however when
you've got a sum
you don't have to worry about these
terms combining together in any
particular way they're just added
right they're not going to be multiplied
and this makes building
these types of expansions much much
easier using these approaches
and so the the the idea behind all of
this
though it can be generalized even
further to this notion of a block
encoding
so what we mean by block encoding is
that what we'd like to do is we'd like
to be able to implement the sum of
unitaries
the sum of unitaries can be hard to
implement because the sum of unitaries
it isn't necessarily unitary now that
that might sound weird but
you can actually see for example i plus
z
over 2 that's equal to the projector
onto zero
so some some of unitaries is can in some
cases be
definitely non-unitary and so
obviously we're not going to be able to
come up with a way of deterministically
implementing this so the idea is okay
what we're going to do is we're going to
take this sum of unitaries
and we're going to build it in to the
into a block
of a larger unitary matrix we'll then
try to build this larger unitary matrix
and use that to uh as our to do our
simulation
okay and for the case of our simulation
what we're
what we'd want to do is we'd want to uh
start with an initial state
which is psi in one of the blocks zero
on the other
and then we'd like to ideally perform
this operation on it
and if we measure the block and we
successfully
end up finding a uh a component up here
then we'll have applied the sum of all
those unitary operators
to the initial state so it gives you a
non-deterministic way of implementing
any sum of unitaries you feel like which
means in principle
any matrix you feel like and that's
amazing power
that this technique ends up affording
and this is one of the reasons why
it's become so popular is that it's
arguably the most flexible
of all the simulation methods that have
been developed so far
so i want to show you uh some specific
intuition behind this
so let's say we wanted to add a whole
bunch of different matrices together
the way that we would do this is say by
using this particular circuit over here
where what we would do is we begin by
preparing
a uniform quantum superposition over
all possible values of this register
then if we've got two to the m
different unitaries that we'd like to
add together what we do
is we do well a zero controlled on zero
uh
u0 then a one controlled u1
so on and so forth all the way down then
we do
hadamard tensor n in the end and in the
event that all of these measurements
turn out to be zero then we enact this
transformation
over here okay so you can and you can go
through the math
it's very simple to validate that this
is uh that this is actually the case
but that is basically how it ends up
working and
you can use various flavors of amplitude
amplification
to be able to boost the success
probability to 100 if you'd like
so that's how we would add a whole bunch
of different matrices together but you
might think
hey wait a second if there's
m qubits up here then the cost of adding
all of these different unitaries
together will have to always go like 2
to the m right because i have to do this
one then this one
all the way down to this one but
actually that ain't true
so i'll get to that in a sec but first i
want to introduce some nomenclature
there's various parts of these types of
circuits
that end up getting used over and over
again the two parts
that we end up getting are the select
and prepare circuit
what the prepair does is it prepares the
weights
or i.e the coefficients for each of
these individual terms
in the sum and select what it does
is it chooses which one of these u's to
apply
all right so those are the two
operations
that we're going to carry out and
actually this paradigm has become so
important
that to be honest it's now the most
common
um oracle model that people consider for
doing hamiltonian simulation
and so a final thing that i want to
bring up
well not quite final is that linear
combinations of unitaries is actually
kind of an analogous to monte carlo
methods
all right so let me explain what i mean
by that so the way that i wanted to get
at it is
first i wanted to get at the fact that
in general the complexity doesn't depend
on the number of terms or the number of
different unitaries we have
to see this let's consider a really dumb
case let's imagine that u0 were equal to
u1
if that were the case then this matrix
over here and that one
are the same which means because the
matrix gets fired
whether this is zero or whether this is
one we can actually simplify
our circuit and the simplification of
the circuit would have no control down
here
so in this particular case you can see
that
um that basically the cost no longer
ends up depending on
2 to the uh on 2 to the n there's just
as many different
possible combinations when you think
about this distribution over here
but when you're actually taking a look
at the cost
now we've reduced the cost by um
by well a small amount in this
particular case but we've reduced it
in general actually all that we need
to do for this is we need to just
consider simplifying the select
so the select subroutine all it needs to
do
is take a j input which specifies a
particular u to apply
and apply it in some cases that can be
much more efficient than the
the original one and to give you an idea
about about this this actually ends up
looking just
like um just like
a monte carlo sampling so imagine what
we wanted to do is we wanted monte carlo
sample
applying a matrix to a vector okay
what we do is we draw we would draw a
randomly a unitary to apply
okay and that's actually what the
prepare circuit is doing here
it's creating a uniform distribution
of what g to apply this corresponds to
some
probability variant that we end up
seeing over here
and then to figure out which one
actually will end up getting applied
we would just kind of look up where it
is in the cumulative distribution
function
and then say oh okay well in this case
21 is the
unitary that ends up getting applied so
that's really what's going on here
except the only difference
is that now rather than this being a
probabilistic
mixture that's going on it's a quantum
mixture
but the cool thing is about this is just
like monte carlo
it actually doesn't directly depend on
the dimension
i.e the number of different unitaries
that are showing up
the only thing that it depends on is how
complicated
it is to do this lookup in the worst
case scenario where this is literally a
lookup table and there's no structure
for it to take advantage
of then yeah that's going to go like 2
to the m but more broadly there's a ton
of structure
that usually ends up existing that we
can take advantage of
to make the cost of this over here in
poly m and in those cases
um we can get some really really nice uh
improvements and so
to give you an example of where this is
or where you can see this i'd like to
turn my attention to a slightly
different problem
i'd like to talk about simulating a
time-dependent hamiltonian
and i only see this as fair because lcu
is just so powerful
that doing something like truncated
taylor that's that's too easy
so let's let's look at simulating a
time-dependent hamiltonian and the
reason why i ultimately want to get to
this
is because of uh the the the
interaction picture simulation method
which i'll be uh
getting to immediately after this so
let's
make the assumption over here just for
simplicity
that uh what we have is that we have
a sub j of t is equal to one
and let's assume over here that
this is just a single term in our
hamiltonian
okay so we've just got one time
dependent term in our hamiltonian
that has a magnitude one
now we'd like to be able to think about
how to write this as a
the dynamics of this is a linear
combination of unitaries
so in order to do this i need to take
that select block
which recall i mentioned is this part
over here that
takes a variant like a value of j that's
input
and looks up which unitary we need to
apply
and so because this is all time
dependent what we need to do is i
we need to now take in the time
as an argument so let's generalize this
a little bit and specify the time
as uh as a quantum input so what select
does is it takes time which is stored
as an integer say in this register and
applies the
unitary hamiltonian which i've just
assumed for the simple cases unitary
to the state now the time evolution
operator
because u of t in general doesn't
necessarily need to commute with itself
although it does for this simple case
it can be written as a as a dyson series
expansion
that looks like this this is sort of the
analog of a taylor series expansion
so the idea behind this expansion over
here
now is that each one of these integrals
that we have is a discrete sum
so the dyson series in this case
actually has already expressed
the time evolution here as a sum of
unitaries
so all we have to do now is just
use this previous circuit over here
to perform the time evolution okay great
and furthermore if there's a simple um a
formula
for figuring out what aj of t is like
like an arithmetic circuit
that can implement the correct phase
kicking back
then this is all going to be doable in
time that's polynomial in a number of
bits of precision
also i should mention that this series
over here
uh truncates very quickly it goes like t
to the k over k factorial
so we really don't need to go very deep
down these nested integrals over here
so the only technic technical issue that
ends up coming up
is just making sure that when we kind of
monte carlo or we use our quantum
circuit
to randomly draw these tnt primes
that their arguments are chosen to be
time ordered
that's the only technicality and so when
you take a look at my paper with
guanghao that we did on this
you know the vast majority of the text
is actually
set up just for making sure that we draw
these times in the appropriate order
um but the sim the idea itself is
actually very simple
we just essentially use lcu to do a
monte carlo average of all of these
integrals
however one of the things that because
this is just like a monte carlo average
the error that we end up getting or the
complexity of this
actually ends up kind of scaling like
the variance
of the quantities which in our case
scales like
the absolute value the sum of the
absolute values
of the a j of t it doesn't
actually end up scaling with the
derivatives in fact the only reason why
the derivatives come in
at all with this kind of monte carlo ish
method for doing quantum simulation
is because of the fact that we need
logarithmically many bits in order to
store the t with enough precision
that's it so basically
what this ends up leading to is this
conclusion that the number
of queries that we need to prepare and
select oracles
in order to do the simulation is totally
independent of the derivatives
and furthermore the number of auxiliary
gates that we need only scales a lot
poly logarithmically
with the derivatives uh through the
length of this t
register over here so that's amazing
every other known uh method uh ends up
having a cost that scales polynomially
with the derivatives
except this one oh i should say
if every other except for the q drift q
drift is the only randomized algorithm
that does this but
i won't have time to go into detail with
that
and this ends up actually opening up a
new possibility which is the interaction
picture
so the idea behind the interaction
picture is um
let me skip ahead i broke this in the
wrong order
um so let's assume that what we want to
do with the interaction picture
is we want to do a frame transform in
order to take a big
part of our hamiltonian out which would
normally
dominate the the cost of the simulation
and turn that time independent
simulation
with a with a huge turn into a rapidly
varying time
dependent simulation because the
previous methods cost doesn't depend on
how rapidly the hamiltonian changes
it only depends on the value that
trade-off can be
actually quite profitable and actually
give you an exponential advantage in
some cases
yeah um there's a question in the chat
that you might want to answer
uh zeph landau asked why is it important
to be talking about
linear combinations of unitaries uh
as opposed to any other operator
okay well deep down it's the same sort
of uh
reason right it's because the
objects that we can we can do naturally
and and cheaply
on the quantum computer are unitary
transformations we could of course
represent you know a linear combination
of non-unitary transformations
but what we'd have to do is we'd have to
propose some method
for implementing those non-uh unitary
transformations and the mo the easiest
way of doing it
is using linear combinations of
unitaries
so that's the that's the biggest reason
it's in principle possible
but we want it we want to make the you
know objects on the right hand side of
the equation simpler than the objects on
the left-hand side of the equation
and so i think i think nathan what uh
what zeph was
uh getting out maybe is that at the end
of the day
you took all these lin you know
unitaries the linear combination of them
and you put them in a block of a matrix
and then you made the the
larger matrix unitary so then where did
it make a difference that the
that the linear combination was of
unitaries of non-unitaries but
where did you actually make use of that
at the end of the day
yeah at the end of the day the main
place where where
we make use of it is um
is actually just in our uh deployment of
the oracle
that's the biggest uh usage that we end
up having for it
so in order to be able to in order to be
we need to be able to come up with a
method of compiling
all of this down to unitary operations
that the quantum computer knows how to
do
and so that's it
so in any case i just wanted to quickly
mention this idea of frame
transformation so
all of you who've done you know
first-year physics
actually have worked with these kinds of
frame transformations like we're using
in the interaction picture
so let's just imagine that we've got
somebody going around in a carousel
it's often more difficult to be able to
solve for the dynamics of this
in an inertial frame of reference
because of the fact that there's some
implicit time dependence
of the carousel going up and down as
it's spinning around
the problem becomes a lot easier if you
remove that time dependence by going
into a co-rotating frame
where the radius of the uh
of the person on the carousel is exactly
the same this leads to problems about
additional potentially fictitious forces
being included in the the
the model but it actually often makes
things simpler
ironically what we want to do here is we
want to do the reverse
we want to start with a system that
looks time independent
and transform over to this case it looks
like an inertial reference frame
the reason why is because these extra
terms that we normally would have had to
have paid full price
or in this picture now become rapid
oscillations like a rapid spin of the
carousel
and because we don't pay a full the full
price for that we only pay a log price
for that
that's favorable and so the key idea
behind this is let's assume that our
hamiltonian is a solid two pieces
we've got big and we've got small yeah i
know real creative names
um so what i want to do is i want to
transform into a rotating frame um
with respect to the big term if i do
that
then the way we can write this is this
interaction picture simulation
or interaction picture transformation
over here
where psi i is the state vector
in this rotating frame the schrodinger
equation once we end up making this
substitution you can just go through the
schrodinger equation
and rewrite it and then you end up
finding
that the hamiltonian in this
rotating frame takes the following form
where it's now
just a small times a rapidly rotating
uh unitary turn but as i said before
we don't pay a price for this rapid
change
uh using the truncated dyson series
simulation method
using lcu that i showed previously and
so
basically the cost only ends up
depending now
on the small bit not the big bit and so
this gives us a way
where actually imagine that a big
is you know goes like 2 to the n and
a small goes like n
in that particular case the advantage
that we can get by going into this
rotating frame can be exponential
so that's something that's really kind
of uh amazing
about the interaction picture simulation
method so
the last method that i want to talk
about is qubitization
and the basic goal behind cubitization
is that what we want to do is we'd like
to be able to build
a simple quantum lock operator that in
some sense is equivalent
to e to the minus iht in a in a higher
dimensional space
the cool thing about this is the
language used to describe
qubitization is exactly the same
language as in linear combination of
unitaries
we have our prepare and our select
circuit where the prepare circuit
ends up building of this alpha state
over here where
in our context alpha
is um just sum over j square root
alpha sub j over a normalization
constant lambda
j and our hamiltonian that we're going
to want to ultimately work with
will be sum over j alpha j uh u j
and select again we'll implement the
corresponding ujs
so that is uh how this works now
what we do is let's just assume for
simplicity we don't need to assume this
but let's assume for simplicity that
select is unitary and hermitian
that means select squared equals one
that also means that select is a
reflection operator
so then this walk operator which i'll
claim
ends up actually implementing a poly a
transformation
of the hamiltonian effectively up to
some isometries
that ends up uh being a reflection
operator
so this over here really for the
particular case
that i'll be discussing is just a pair
of reflection operators
so this ends up looking exactly like
grover's search
so we can understand what this walk
operator which i've
given over here does so this
first thing we have to apply the select
operator we can go through and if we
represent the initial state
which is this alpha tensor e k this over
here i've assumed is an eigen
value or an eigen
vector and this over here again
it stores all the coefficients of h
okay so initially let's assume we start
with all of those coefficients of h in
quantum superposition
up here tensored with an eigenvector we
begin by preparing applying the select
operation
which we can actually argue is a
reflection
about this up to a global face now
what we need to do is we need to do the
following reflection about the prepare
state
which is the initial state so when we do
that we're going to reflect about this
and end up right back here and so this
looks exactly like the analysis
behind grover search exactly like it in
fact you can actually just
regurgitate everything out of mike and
ike in order to go through and figure
out
what the form of the rotation operator
inside this two-dimensional space is
when you do that you end up finding that
the
uh rotation the the rotation operator
inside this two-dimensional space
takes this form which we can simplify
to that matrix over here so we can see
that this walk operator
ends up being very having eigenvalues
that are
look exactly like the previous ones
except
that these ones were going to be plus
minus the arc
cosine of the original eigenvalues
rather than
just the eigenvalues so we can fix that
up
using a set of techniques known as
quantum signal processing
you can also use linear combinations of
unitaries to fix this up
or other you know in most cases actually
we don't even bother trying to fix it up
because normally if we're interested in
learning the energies
say for a chemistry simulation problem
well it's good enough to just
do phase estimation on w and then take a
cosine of the answer
we don't need to use any fancy tricks in
order to quantumly
transform the arc cosine back when we
use a calculator
so that's the the core idea behind
behind how we use the um cubitization
so if you learn nothing more from this
talk
i would say this slide is probably as
ugly as it is
the most useful slide in the entire deck
because
what it gets across is why
we would want to use these different
techniques now i want to
reiterate none of the techniques is
strictly better than
any of the other techniques there's
always things that one of these three
methods does better than the rest
trotter suzuki methods
don't scale as well when it comes to the
air tolerance or
the evolution time as the other methods
however they require no extra cubits
and on top of that their air depends on
the commutators
not how big the individual terms are so
there are going to be some problems with
big terms and small commutators where
the trotter suzuki error that we end up
getting over here
is far far better than the sum of the
absolute values of the coefficients that
we get
here the
lcu methods they're incredibly flexible
you can do just about
everything that you want with them
downside is
that we don't get the quite as good
scaling
as cubitization which is optimal
and but we end up the technique works
for
time dependent hamiltonians and also
allows us to do
through that the interaction picture
qubitization
its big advantage is that it's got the
provably optimal query complexity
and so if the place to use it really is
if there's no self-evident symmetry
in the particular problem that you're
you're working with it you could take
advantage of using
lcu or trotter in that those cases
cubanization is your sledgehammer
and that's the one that you should
really swing at those particular
problems and
that's why for problems in chemistry in
particular
cubitization is usually my favorite
method
but for other problems that might have
more structure i i tend to prefer
trotter or lcu methods
so now what i'd like to do is i'd like
to give you very quickly
an introduction to three different
simulation uh
applications that we've taken a look at
one
uh chosen each uh to end up uh
um so that they're one each each of
uh of them is uh optimal for one of the
different methods that i've discussed
so the first one that i'll discuss is
quantum electrodynamics
simulations and in particular what we're
going to look at
is the uh simulation of the schwinger
model which is qe
models qed in one plus one dimensions
now i won't bother going too much into
the details
of how this model works but the basic
idea is that
each of these individual sites you can
think of is just a cubit
so this is you know like zero or one
that stores whether there's an electron
or a positron here
this green bar over here think of this
as a q
did it's a register uh that would cut
off lambda
over there that ends up determining how
much electric field or electric flux
there there is uh between the two sites
and so basically the interactions in
this particular system
between the electrons and positrons and
electrons and other electrons
aren't mitigated by uh like putting in a
direct force in there
all of it is inferred by gauss's law
from
the fluxes that we end up seeing out
here
in any case the hamiltonian is this guy
over here
key thing about all of this is that
the electric energy that we end up
getting ends up
scaling like the sum of the squares of
the values up here
so if we have n sites here this
would be order n lambda squared
for it now lambda is often a big big
number because
we don't know how the electric field is
going to group for
the dynamics of a bunch of electrons or
positrons even in one dimension so we've
got to make sure
that we keep enough inside each of these
locations
in order to be able to store a huge
electric field
and so this term ends up dominating the
sum
however there's only one term that it
actually
ends up having a non-trivial uh
commentator
with which is this interaction term oh
this bottom one over here is just the
mass
of the individual ones and because of
the fact that the commutators are nice
well that just screams use trotter
suzuki on this guy
so that's what we did um this is work i
did with
um um jesse stryker
alex shaw palva lugowski
and so what we ended up finding for this
particular case
is that if lambda again is the cutoff t
is the evolution time
n is the number of fermionic sites the
cost for trotter suzuki it scales a
little bit worse when it comes to the
evolution time and a number of sites
than cubitization but it scales
quadratically better with the cutoff
and so for in this case we save qubits
and we save
time by using actually a simpler quantum
simulation method
than cubitization so that's one of the
reasons why
it's really important to know not just
which
technique ends up giving an abstract the
best uh
of the best uh performance but rather
you need to know why it gives it so that
way you can choose the
right technique to take advantage of the
structure in your particular problem
another one i i promise you an
interaction picture example
let's talk about simulating materials in
a plane wave dual basis
so this hamiltonian that i drew over
here this
is the hamiltonian that basically just
describes a coulomb hamiltonian so it's
the ordinary hamiltonian
that describes electrostatic attraction
and repulsion between
electrons nuclei that works so this
really describes all of chemistry
the only thing that we ended up uh
assuming on top of that
is we ended up assuming that we have a
periodic lattice which ends up reduced
killing off some of the terms that would
have been present otherwise but
so this really is kind of most
appropriate for materials
in any case key thing about this is that
we have this term over here this ends up
giving the energy
for two electrons talking to each other
so we've got two electrons
at different sites in your lattice say
here and here
this term ends up giving you the energy
of it where n
counts the presence or of an electron at
a given site
and so this term actually ends up
dominating
the cost of the simulation it is far
bigger than
any of the other ones and it's also
diagonal
which means that it's actually easy to
fast forward and use with the
interaction picture
so when we transform into an interaction
frame
of this guy which is our biggest
offender
we end up getting complexity for the
simulation
that scales like n squared t
whereas if we use qubitization which i
remind you can't take advantage
of the interaction picture the
asymptotic complexity goes more like
n to the eleven thirds and so
this shows an example of where you can
take advantage of
knowing structure for the particular
hamiltonian that you're you're looking
at
uh to end up getting an advantage
through the interaction picture
now finally as i said before you know
there's the there's the big sledgehammer
in the
in the game and you're going to want to
take the sledgehammer out from time to
time
and chemistry is exactly the right kind
of problem for this
so for chemistry we're looking we were
looking at in this
paper with um the folks at google uh
as well as uh uh juno lee
the um we were looking at the
simulation of this molecule that i've uh
i've unfortunately inflicted upon the
field called famoco
don't worry i'm not going to talk about
biological nitrogen fixation
but anyways the um key thing is
is that this molecule is very
complicated and expressed in an
extremely complicated basis
so any structure which might have been
self-evident has been washed away
in all of the quantum chemistry packages
and because that's all gone then this is
a perfect target
for a method that works well in brute
force situations
like cubitization and we end up finding
actually
world-leading results in this where we
showed that this molecule can basically
be simulated
on the order of a few billion operations
which is a world records to my knowledge
for a useful simulation problem but it's
worth mentioning
actually that all that these afford
techniques down at the bottom actually
are all cubitization and it's not a
coincidence
it's because of the fact that the
problem doesn't really lend itself
to being torn apart using any of the
other approaches
and so that's why we hit it with the
asymptotically best method
and we get the best results for that
so those are hopefully some ideas
there's some intuition
that i can give you about what the
different hamiltonian simulations uh do
and why you should use them one of the
things
that though there's a bunch of open
questions i think that are raised
once you have these basic tools there's
many questions about how to end up using
them properly with each other
first question is well we've got these
three methods right
none of them end up strictly beating
each other so the question is
are there ways that we can borrow can we
can we
figure out ways of intelligently using
some of the features of trotter some of
the features
of um lcu or cubitization
and put them together in such a way as
to take advantage
of partial structure in parts of parts
of a harder problem
and recent work that i've done with uh
guanghao as well as video including
has shown that you can do we can do this
with multi-product formulas but i feel
there's a lot more work
left to be done in this particular space
another
issue is that because of the fact that
cubitization
doesn't work for time-dependent
hamiltonians we really
actually can't get the optimal scaling
with the the error for um
for time-dependent simulations because
lcu
scales multiplicatively with the
logarithm of the air tolerance not
additively
and so an open question that i that i'm
really curious about is
is it possible to bridge that gap can
you can you
uh come up with a simulation algorithm
for time-dependent hamiltonians in
general
that's going to have uh additive
complexity in the logarithm of the air
but a bigger question is well not all of
quantum dynamics has
naturally has a hamiltonian there's
actually many problems in quantum field
theory where it's much more natural to
begin with a lagrangian
rather than a hamiltonian and so the
question is
in one of these approaches such as the
path integral formalism or
if you're thinking even more funky like
you know what about some
other really strange vision of quantum
dynamics like
um say uh say simulating
um bohmian mechanics
it are these just as efficient as
present-day quantum simulation methods
or are there additional considerations
that need to be made so
my hope is that will eventually
transition beyond
hamiltonian simulation and have a more
complete understanding of what
simulating quantum dynamics
looks like under assumptions about
different
types of oracles than the kind that we
currently have which only give us
information about the hamiltonian
and this question i hope will actually
eventually allow us to
shed some light on to me what one of the
biggest open questions for quantum
computing is
which is the question of whether or not
quantum computers
actually can simulate all of physical
theory and in particular
whether they can simulate the standard
model of physics and
having quantum simulation methods that
can meet the descriptions that
physicists
use for these more esoteric models
in the middle i think we might
potentially offer a valuable step
towards this goal of understanding
really what the computational power of
the universe is
thank you very much
thanks nathan um thanks for the great
talk let's um
we should turn to questions um yes
um so samuel palmer asks which of these
techniques are most relevant for nist
devices
by far hands down no questions asked
trotter
the reason why is that for nisk devices
uh cubits come at a major premium
and so for that reason having a space
optimal method like trotter suzuki
is uh is actually the best um
the other thing though that's also worth
taking a look at
is some of the randomized simulation
methods like like
q drift or other variants that
that are related to it those also are
space optimal
another question by nicolas savaya is
that
well it says that you are covering
electronic structure in
two of the three like examples that you
had
and unlike in one one was more
advantages than
other and and he continues like do you
have a sense for which hamiltonian
simulation method will be best for
qubit-based simulations of ozones
including
molecular and material vibrations of the
both compact morels
ah excellent question excellent
excellent question
yeah um okay so for bosons
bosons are tough because of the fact
that what you
have is uh you have this exact same
problem with the schwinger model
where you have to deal with very large
cutoffs and the compilation uh
using most of the techniques that people
have shown so far in the space
down to simple unitaries actually is
inefficient
so um i the the approach that i think
is best uh to do is so far
seems to actually be the interaction
picture um
because of the fact that we i generally
in order to be able to
um the cutoffs that i often have to
worry about
for bosonic models for uh for the
bosonic degrees of freedom can often be
quite large and i don't want to have to
pay full price for them
and so by going into a rotating frame i
can ignore that
and so so far preliminary work that i've
done seems to suggest that that's
asymptotically going to be the right way
of going about it but if you're looking
for the nisk
going back to the previous question i
think that um
i think that a randomized approach is
like
a time dependent q drift uh in the
interaction frame is actually going to
be the best way of doing with that
okay i have one more question uh so
in one of the last slides you you showed
some new
new results where you achieved the best
uh complexity so far for
for tomoko and other simulations
and and you said that it's a it's it's
based on some tensor hyper contract
uh hyper contraction uh techniques
can you just say a word on what that
means sure
so basically what the the whole idea is
is that
what we do is we normally when we're
doing electronic structure we have all
of these different terms
that are generated by the electronic
structure package and there's no real
self-evident structure that's exposed to
the human for this
so what we do is we can actually
re-express
that sum as a as a
contraction of a set of tensors
and then once we form that we have this
ability to now be able to do a singular
value
um truncation
of those tensors that we end up forming
which allow us to kind of control
the amount of accuracy that we end up
getting versus the
number of terms that the whole thing
ends up expanding into
and this is this is one of the key
things that ends up giving us a big
advantage
the other advantage that we end up
getting which actually is more
interesting from an algorithmic
perspective
is that we actually formally are working
in a non-orthogonal basis
uh when we're we're doing this so
actually our
our basis vectors when we represent the
simulation have some actual
you know small overlap with each other
and we use this
in order to allow it to actually explore
a higher dimensional hilbert space
and partially compensate for the um
error we get
from truncating some of the singular
values of these tensors
and that's what and we're doing this
gives us slightly better asymptotic
scaling theoretically
if we're willing to accept these these
errors along the way and we make some
assumptions about
how the singular values behave but
the um the the in practice
really all of this hard work boiled down
to a factor of two better than the the
best previous result
so we're starting to get to the point
where there are continual
mammoth you know advances that are
happening but now we're now we're
beginning to fight over factors of two
and uh that to me is kind of you know
exciting and
uh you know frightening all at the same
time
so actually continuing on that um
i guess i had questions at two ends of
the spectrum one is um
given that you're already at these
factors of two so how
you know um i'm not sure i misread
whether i misread the
numbers on the previous slide in terms
of the number of qubits but uh
sorry in the next one yeah yeah so
uh so the uh
as you can see this is clearly a nisk
application
yes so so uh so what what what do you
think
you know what are the prospects of of
something useful being being possible on
on you know nisk like or
you know at what stage would something
useful happen and
where in all this do you see this
happening
truth is is that i really don't know if
somebody
um i don't know exactly where this is
going going to happen but the gulfs
between the numbers of what we can do
right now
and these which are still the best like
to my knowledge these are the absolute
best numbers anybody's ever found
for a uh useful application for a
quantum computer
golf is just so wide between that that
even if this is pessimistic by a factor
of 100
when it comes to the gate count we're
still many orders of magnitude away
from what we realistically could do i
think that
if we're hoping that we're going to see
some sort of an advantage
from niskara hardware it's got to be for
a completely different application and i
don't know what that application would
be
yeah and then um at the other end of the
spectrum where you were talking about
um uh simulating the standard model on a
on a on a quantum computer so
um can you can you go over
what the what the gaps there are
wonderful yeah so the basic idea
behind this is that the the biggest
problem is that the
standard model from the perspective of
an algorithms guy is that the standard
out uh
model is all given in terms of
lagrangian which is isn't a matrix
like uh like we would you'd be dealing
with a hamiltonian
it's literally like an energy function
that and that where you end up giving
um basically uh two positions and you
can
figure out what the lagrangian density
or the integral of it
is between these and it turns out that
if you use a the path integral
representation
for quantum dynamics then the
time evolution can be described as a sum
over all possible trajectories
that a particle could follow from the
beginning
of some process to some final
configuration
where the phase that that particle will
end up picking up
will be given by the integral of the
lagrangian
so what you have to do with that
simulation if you want to do that
literally
exactly as written is you have to sum
over this exponentially large number of
paths
with all of these terms that are wildly
oscillating up and down
and the problem is is that the vast
majority of these
paths are going to almost entirely
cancel but if you use a technique like
linear combination of unitaries
the cost ends up scaling like the
absolute value of the sum of all of
those terms that are cancelling out
so you actually get something that's
very analogous to the sign
problem if you try to implement
literally
uh the dynamics in a path integral
formalism
so i'm sorry i'm not i'm not really
following you know so
so the the kind of problems you're
raising about um
you know cancellations and so on well
that that's exactly what a quantum
computer helps us do so
so you know but in terms of your
formulation
uh what what is it that's different so
so you you're not given a hamiltonian
but you're given
so what's what's it what's the what's
the small
input to the problem which describes the
initial conditions and
and the dynamics that that that we
wanted
is that the paths that you're summing
over
there's no a priori importance about the
paths
so if you have an oracle coming in that
oracle may not
have any idea about whether or not some
trajectory that it could consider
is going to be more uh lead to more
cancellation than another
when if we've got a hamiltonian
especially a sparse one right
we know that the dynamics is going to be
confined to some sort of an area
but we don't have any spatial
information whatsoever
when we just specify it in the path
integral representation
we only have the degree of phase
cancellation and the quantum computer
i i've never figured it out and i don't
believe anybody else has
figured out a way of actually
without having promises about either
locality for the lagrangian
or importances of these different paths
that you're summing up
i really don't know how to efficiently
implement that sum
even on a quantum computer
and so that's one of the big challenges
and i i think
part of me thinks that the original
problem as stated
might actually be uh in a in a
complexity class that's too hard for
quantum computers to realistically be
able to pull it off
but i haven't been able to prove it
that's just my crazy conjecture
and so this is going beyond the fact
that um beyond quantum field theory and
whether that's that can be simulated and
so from that perspective
what my conjecture is is that there's a
lot more information that's provided
in a hamiltonian-based formalism of
dynamics than a lagrangian-based
formalism even if the two are
technically equivalent
and the and the extra information
can sometimes allow us to come up with
an efficient method for simulating it on
a quantum computer
but nobody knows how to do it without
that extra information
uh great if there are no other questions
we can we can continue to continue the
discussion in small groups on gathertown
uh i wonder if he can put it on the on
the chat uh
let me try to put the link on the chat
um but um
yeah in the you know uh
uh you know thanks again for for a
really
uh uh very thought broken
talk and
let me let me just put
[Music]
put the the gather town link
on the on the chat and on the q a
so thanks everybody for attending and
and
thanks nathan again thank you everybody
for for coming